aged 15 zan moon was sexually abused by
a school boy at a party
she's one of a number of young women
who've pushed for change since the
everyone's invited website
allowed school children to share their
stories of abuse anonymously
and this week she was invited to the
department of education
so i'm going to go in and ask them to
update the curriculum so that we have
sex education as a standalone subject
that boys can be tested on consent i
think there needs to be
more support and accessibility for
victims so that we can
easily come forward and there needs to
be a rehabilitation program
for the boys and the perpetrators so
that when they offend
they're not just punished but educated
now the school's inspectorates calling
for similar changes after its
investigation found sexual harassment
was normalized among school children
it found nearly 90 of girls and nearly
50 percent of boys
said being sent explicit pictures or
videos of things
they didn't want to see happens a lot or
sometimes to them or their peers
sexist abuse was equally common and it
was often reported
that boys collected nude photos of the
girls
and shared them on social media
investigators were told
some of the boys had a sense of
entitlement and had never been told no
they talked about a sense of male
superiority
in the school i must ask the minister
why has it taken so long
labour says there were warnings of this
problem back in 2016.
the government says it did act then but
it will do
more now we first introduced the
statutory safeguarding
guidance back in 2015 we update it
every year we also introduced the new
compulsory
relationships and sex and health
education
curriculum and we will now be working as
i said very closely
with schools to make sure that they have
the support as it becomes more
compulsory
helen pike is master of maudlin college
school in oxford which was named on
everyone's invited
she welcomed the issue being exposed but
warns
things need to be handled fairly as the
ofsted report really sensibly says there
is a danger of over criminalizing
children and some quite unfortunate
demonizing parallels have been drawn
here and
i think we need to look at cultures and
environments
in which young people and you know
particularly boys and the examples
you've given
make unfortunate and sometimes illegal
decisions
department of education says teachers
will be better supported
ofsted says schools should assume that
they do have a problem
even if they think they don't jason
farrell sky news